Từng là dòng kinh Danh đặc bốc mùi xuất gần 20 năm,
khiến tham lương này đang dành lột sác sau hơn 30 cải tạo.
Đây là kinh dành nhất thành cô sinh mình với hơn 32 kí lồ mẹ,
tổng bố đầu trư hơi chiến những tỷ đầu.
Đến này dự án đã hoàn thành hơn 20,000 chăm cuối lượng.
Không chuyện ngày nó có là một thời hồn hợp nhờ nhiều khi hạm mục quôn kè,
hay người cánh bằng cái đứng.
Đừng cho thông 2 bên, chưa dòng, lòng đường là 1 2 mẹt và về hẹn.
Từ 2 đến 5 mẹt, làm kè và đường cho thông 1 là 2 kè hàng mục đường.
Thì công tốt nhất, đang khó khá nhất.
Đó là hàng mục nào vét.
Tung tối chưa có nào vét được có tử một mệt hối nào.
Lý do là hiện nay vậy rồi,
người đất nào vét theo quy định chưa được cơ quan có thông quyền trước hợp.
Cô vực gần như công quyền của nó có góc là gần như là thấy hình 2,
rất là rạo ra hàng trong đó là có đầy dụ cả kè hàng mục.
Như là đà tham nhiều.
Đà đáu ngông kè giữa ngược đà lắp lắm cán.
Và hiện nay là nhà thông đàn tiếp tục công chủ điện.
Cái xanh đáp kì về hẹn trong người đi vọng.
Hoàn thành cho kế kế mục tiêu dự án trong người chá tất.
Đó quá đẹp.
Dạ thì mình bà còm đi vào nặp giống rất là quá.
Hãy chỉ dự án như nó nó có tử dụng rồi.
Nhưng mà mong mai vì ra mới là hẹn tự.
Cứ đường này nó đang gây loạn hoàn thiết.
Thế rất bắt đầu đẹp rồi.
Chúc này nó bãi lòng buồn dầy.
Sình đây.
Cái chắc là cũng được này nó phản ra mùi đi nữa thôi.
Mái không không bị vô gây, không bị vụi giống như thế xưa nó.
Theo kế hoạch công trình sẽ hoàn thành vào cuối năm 2020.
Dự án giúp hắt nước, giảm gặp cho các khu vật giọt chuyển.
Hình thành chục rao thông thủy bộ kết nối thành vô chiming với lọng an và các tỉnh miền đông,
mà không phải đi qua chung tâm.
Gó phần giảm uống tác, thuộc đẩy rú lịch, vẫn chuyển hàng hoá,
đồng thời trị trang đô thị và cải thiện mua trường.